I was interested in Armstrong but to
begin with because he is the most
important figure in jazz in the 20th
century there's simply no question about
it I mean if you're going to compare
them to somebody it's Shakespeare in
terms of centrality of the tradition and
being at the beginning of that I don't
draw this comparison in the book because
it's not really relevant but I mean that
gives you a sense of how how big he is
in the history of jazz I could have
written a book about Charlie Parker it
just happened that when I was out on
tour for my last full-length biography a
book about HL Mencken I'd gone through a
long horrible day of book touring and
personal appearances and I staggered
back to the hotel and sort of fell on
the bed and it was like somebody hit me
in the forehead and said Armstrong it
was really like that and the seed had
been planted a couple of years before
when I had met Michael Cogswell who runs
the Armstrong archives in the house
museum I was writing a piece about about
the house museum for the New York Times
and Michael said to me have you ever
thought about writing a biography of
Louis Armstrong and at this moment I was
in the middle of writing another book
and the last thing you want to hear
about is the next book you should write
so I sort of fluffed him off but
obviously the seed dropped at some point
and that day at the first day of the
Meccan tour I thought Armstrong the next
morning I called my agent we began the
process of negotiation and having
written a biography a full-length
primary source biography I had a
checklist in my mind of the things that
make a biography practical is the source
material centralized is it easy to find
are there new primary sources that no
one has ever had access to are all the
sources in English if they're not are
they in a language that you speak you
know little nuts and bolts things like
that I ran down the checklist I realized
that not only is Armstrong the most
important figure in the jazz in 20
century but he's a perfect subject for a
biography for all of these reasons it
was practical and it excited me because
I'd always loved his music and I had
been fascinated in him as a personality
and that's really the key to writing a
biography if you're not interested in
the
personality in the inner life of your
subject you have the wrong subject